un gabinete listo para liderar el mundo
así presentó formalmente el presidente
estadounidense electo joe biden a
quienes asumirán los cargos en su
gabinete en política extranjera y
seguridad nacional
el demócrata confirmó el nombre de
anthony blinken como futuro secretario
de estado se trata de un cercano
consejero de wyden y abanderado del
multilateralismo
tenemos que proceder con las mismas
medidas de humildad y confianza humildad
porque como dijo el presidente electo no
podemos resolver todos los problemas del
mundo solos necesitamos trabajar con
otros países necesitamos su cooperación
necesitamos su apoyo de ser confirmado
por el senado este gabinete podría
contar por primera vez con un latino a
la cabeza de seguridad nacional hay un
giro de 180 grados con el equipo de
trump al tratarse del departamento que
determina las políticas migratorias se
trata de alejandro mayorkas nacido en su
hijo de exiliados y ex fiscal general de
california mi padre y mi madre me
trajeron a este país para escapar del
comunismo porque ellos valoran nuestra
democracia y se sentían profundamente
orgullosos
de que yo fuera ciudadano de eeuu igual
que yo lo siento
otro cambio notable se produciría en
inteligencia nacional que tendría a la
cabeza por primera vez a una mujer será
abril james segunda al mando en la cia
durante el gobierno obama estos son
algunos de los nombres que confirman el
cambio de rumbo que quiere para su país
el demócrata howard dean quien asumirá
la presidencia el 20 de enero